Stasi arrange a meeting scooter why are
we having this conversation your job is
a no-brainer you act cute mommy and
daddy give you food and shelter you
doozy they doozy how do we move the
needle on this one bus key talk to me
what do you say sordid things about our
mother better you don't know
I see we issue a recall take them back
to the baby court take him away you
can't do that I thought we were supposed
to help him Stacy I like the
problem-solving and lack of morals but
the kids are ice we don't need drastic
measures what have I been teaching you
Templeton dad I owe you a favor I lost
interest after you promised me cookies
it's all business we just need to find
out what scooter busky wants bus key
let's do some business that was hard
cash you maniac
we are back to work Templeton hello you
beautiful baby car bosses Brothers are
they always this friendly I can't have
my own brother ignorant to the art of
business it's embarrassing I make sure
the world loves babies more than puppies
more than kittens what's the threat what
cats don't play by rules fade up the
company's in your mashed potato hands
don't blow it just kidding of course you
will what's up
this meeting is making me uncomfortable
I'm gonna bag the tiger this is my job
on the line you made a choice to join a
family we can fix this what if you broke
up and landed on the cab yes boom
starfish they say in fairness sir the
cat thought of it first
you can't kill what you can't see time
to go mommy is a dirty liar
[Music]
you